n'était pas là le 8 février dernier le
joueur de west ham choeur d'hommes avait
provoqué l'indignation courte soumah qui
maltraitait son chat l'image très
violent ferme thomas qui est lâché par
son sponsor adidas
en cause une vidéo on le voit mal traité
son chat à plusieurs reprises devant ses
enfants
si plusieurs fondations avaient porté
plainte de nombreuses personnalités
s'étaient désolidarisés de son geste ces
images sans sang chaud quand elle est
insupportable car zuma et son frère qui
filmait la scène ont été condamnés à 180
heures de travaux d'intérêt général
aucun traitement de faveur donc pour le
joueur qui a dû enfiler les gants pour
accomplir sa tâche alors que dumas doit
ramasser des poubelles en public une
bonne chose
moi des crânes haug est encore très bien
très bien parce que c'était de max
aviation bon je sais pas si on peut
humilier un animal mais en tout cas la
belge semblait canberra publication et
là il va faire quelque chose qui va lui
évidemment il semblait millan parce que
voilà et je trouve ça très très bien
français sans ce sont des gens
intelligents moi cette sanction elle me
choque parce qu'elle n'est pas assez
sévère et que ça sous-entend qu'en fait
tabasser son chat c'est pas si grave on
s'en soient réglés travaux d'intérêt
général et que tout le monde peut
tabassé son chat et ce qui me choque en
plus c'est que pardon mais ramasser les
poubelles c'est un métier et en fait on
sanctionne des gens très riches en leur
infligeant entre guillemets le métier de
certains dansaient le quotidien de ce
qu'ils auraient mérité c'est une bonne
amende et de la prison avec sursis
sa fiche de ce qui est très bien c'est
que d'habitude quand ce sont des
personnalités en angleterre n 1 et peine
à domicile haché et là on l'exhibé
publiquement justement pour qu'il expie
cet acte donc guillaume franchement
c'est une manière de lui montrer que
c'est répréhensible et c'est une manière
de l'humiliant public donc moi je trouve
c'est une très belle sanctions mais
voilà le
but est d' humilier là en l'occurrence
le but le but de la loi n'était pas
d'humilier célia prison ferme c'est ce
qu'il a ce qu'il a fait il a maltraité
un animal aujourd'hui un animal est
considéré comme un être humain mais je
suis désolé il a maltraité un animal il
fait effectivement une près d'une peine
de prison avec sursis ou ferme c'est pas
des travaux d'intérêt général comme s'il
avait fait une quelconque bêtise c'est
pas une bêtise de frapper un animal
c'est la justice qui a tranché c'est pas
vous la justice et à la main d'oeuvre à
dire que je suis fait des conneries et
cabotine également petite 1st les chéris
qu'il avait l'intention de s'en prendre
prochainement un american staff
[Rires]
oui répond c'est bien parce que comme ça
il a vu ce que c'était de travailler
pour de vrai et quand il verra ce que
celle satin la dépression sinon
une amende de 300 milles c'était
vachement bien et surtout ce que j'aime
bien c'est le métier avant lui c'est
rien pour lui c'est comme ça c'est pour
aller je vous dis remis ça serrières
pour lui je vais pas là mais
c'est vrai pour lui c'est bien pour lui
c'est noir désir une semaine alors dans
ce cas là tu vas dire à bayel c'est pas
guillaume et rival trois cent mille
euros c'est une prison
qui va là on a 300 euros pour menacer
mais non maximales c'est la
justice en plus médaillées d'amande
parce que là ça n'a rien avec la ctu
fait que les amendes là c'est pas il est
pas au lait d'amande
non mais alors oui les 300000 euros par
le club par le club travaille surtout
arrière terry ginals et c'est bien pour
lui même pour lui c'est bien c'est
surtout que des fois on fait rien là au
moins on a fait quelque chose et on a
envoyé un message à dire aux autres à
regarder ce qui peut vous arriver avec
ses larbins mais j'avais dit que c'était
pas grave on te dis juste que les
sanctions des fois il n'y a pas de
sanctions ça j'aime bien ça avance trois
cent mille euros et là ça avant la vue
là c'est partie de sa tournée dans le
monde entier assure maintenant avis aux
amateurs et peut-être là mandat sera
plus grand de l'enfant avis aux amateurs
la prison ferme moi j'aime bien quand
servant avis aux amateurs chaud comme ça
je suis d'accord avec guillaume sait pas
c'est pas une humiliation à ce qu'il
entre j'ai pas de célébration j'ai dit
c'est dans les tuyaux d'identié mais en
fait on a vu l'image de coeur d'une
accord va travailler dans le monde
entier mais je ne trouve pas humilier de
la médiatisation de cette image est très
dur pour lui de l'avis du coiffeur mais
pas pour le millième pas que c'est bien
mérité mais même pour retrouver un autre
club pour sa carrière internationale
sont faits
les chiffres et je vous demandais juste
de ne pas parler trop fort les amours
vous risqueriez de réveiller benjamin
est-ce qui est réglementé ou peu
parlé mais tranquille douceur en bleu et
jaune dit je suis d'accord avec mathieu
et je suis d'accord avec kelly et je
suis d'accord avec mathieu et avec lui
parce que je trouve que l'amande hockey
adidas qui perd adidas ok mais je trouve
qu'il ya un truc alors dont on lui met
un gilet jaune ils ramassent les
poubelles et c'est bon c'est bon t'es
nettoyer tout moi je trouve que c'est
trop facile je pense qu'on aurait des
envies vous étiez avec lui cet après
midi je sens qu'on y aurait on aurait dû
lui imposé d'être au contact des animaux
ou aider des personnes ou aider des
jeunes à voir un truc de transmission
pour apprendre la bienveillance à
l'adversaire les champs
je trouve que c'est trop embrasse iborra
leur foi quelle belle et devient c'est
la punition ultime joker désobligeant
pour les jambes c'est vrai métier ouest
a dit vous voulez zaman avis
honnêtement sur ça je suis d'accord avec
guillaume je suis d'accord avec
géraldine suis d'accord à cette année
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et je ne vois
pas une opa sur il dormait pas
complètement voilà j'étais à l'écouté on
sait que quelques bribes à trépas qu'il
était préférable de mettre au contact
des animaux je suis d'accord avec gerald
mccoy les gens plus intelligents que moi
sur le bateau je vois moi j'aime bien
qu'ils aillent travailler comme ça c'est
moi ça mais je fais pas de travail et je
ne trouve pas ça plutôt qu'il arrive
avec ses sponsors cmec ses copains et
qu'ils aillent dans un refuge qu'ils
fassent des selles fief des animaux
genre veut regarder je suis par des noms
on sait très bien que tu as fait ça mais
des années il va travailler footballeur
c'est un travail éléments me mais
peut-on vraiment être autour des plats
et manuel on ne travaille pas refaire
ton problème tu écoute moi bien toi
tombe dit le mahb et écoute je vais
aller j'ai joué au foot mais pas
travailler je vais jouer alors un
footballeur c'est super bien joué
attendu que tu vas gagner trois points
du piano les jo c'est pas trop mal je
sais ça
moi ces voleurs c'est un métier chez
jouéclub
mais alors c'est pas une passion
animateur c'est une passion à terre
célébration ce n'est pas sur les
pensionnats pas mal c'est parce que
jamais d'accord on jouera jamais
d'accord sur quoi on sera jamais
allés faire du football à meschers
travail c'est un métier difficile ce
sont les besoins d'éducation c'est leur
métier pas là bas y ont passé leur
métier parce qu'on dit footballeur
lionel m'a bien sûr mais c'est une
passion est devenue le faire depuis que
j'étais tout petit chauffeur livreur
général amélie silva pour aller bouffer
terrasse qui flotte dans sa
missive à bonbons mange et yappa pourra
tuer le sahara touché 600 mille euros et
bien sûr que c'est un peu aigri du toit
c'est vrai que je
suis content qu'elle bafé touche autant
d'argent
je
[Rires]
[Musique]
il n'est pas ça ça d'une carrière
il se défendre et moyens de vous parler
des acteurs
fait l'écho de cinéma le temps de
pousser
mathieu guertin chronique
et d'animatrice télé du foot comme se
sert dans à parler pour moi c'est donc
j'ai joué ya le mot gentil bonheur c'est
une joie je voulais pas même un bout
sur vêtements ils vont faire des vers à
l'ail joue comme un jogging joue à la
baballe ils font des entraînements
ici cavale et physiquement c'est très
dur et je suis bien placé pour savoir
qu'il arrive j'ai dit c'est dit c'est
les méthodologies mais tu plais mec même
quand tu parle avec eux s'ils s'ils
pensent que c'est un travail un travail
ça dure dix ans c'est alors gilbert et
même beaucoup mais là tes délires l'ena
le mail anciens cdd lire ce que tu dis
jamais tu devais te dire à partir moment
que tu es producteur d'une boîte que
this thing 250 ch et 150 livres à placer
à manger à des familles cela partait
émission tu fais
ravalement footballeur qui
[Applaudissements]
passion c'est ma tante et l'audition de
josette darrigade
c'est insupportable et beaucoup centre
est où là c'est génial voulais qu'ils
recommencent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
ça c'est un vrai travail d'être
producteur d'aller dans des rivières on
n'enseigne
pas plus
eh ben c'est tout en bas ce mec là les
majeures sont fermés
mais porsche sont fermés combien de fois
on lui a refusé
la radio c'est pas pour toi 20 ans la
télé c'est pas pour toi les avenues je
le voyais les jours je sors je livrais
je dis qu'est-ce que vous faites
monsieur noonan du off je roule ma bosse
on verra bien si ça marche je
vous l'avais le mental pour arriver là
aujourd'hui
tout argent qu on crachait sur lui qu'on
n'y arrivera jamais prêté en vaut rien
donc dans ses amis dans sa
toge et rui ils arrivent ici avec une
ferme alors que j'ai mesuré du travail
tous les matins tous les matins il s'est
mis en face des gens qui ont dit non des
gens qui nous ont dit on prend pas ça
[Applaudissements]
ta vie tu n'y arriveras il a raison
aujourd'hui il est là et même pour lui
dire est ce que tu peux me donner du
travail et ça c'est non bravo
[Applaudissements]